on this National Day of Prayer Michelle
Obama who was never proud of her country
until it elected her husband president
refers to herself in a speech at Temple
University as our forever first lady
thankfully she's actually Dean ever ever
again first lady Israeli Prime Minister
Bibi Netanyahu reveals a shocking
intelligence operation that proves
Barack Obama practically gave Iran
nuclear weapons and threatened the world
order thankfully he is not president
anymore and finally in what is sure to
become a new daily segment we rejoice in
the media fallout over Kanye West's
newfound conservatism there is so much
to be grateful for this National Prayer
day then the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to be thankful for so many
reasons to rejoice especially thinking
of terrible days gone by before we do
that I have another reason to rejoice
which is that we have a wonderful
sponsor that helps keep the lights on
and actually turns both me and the
audience from rotten dirty skilless
derelicts into people who can actually
do something productive in this world
I'm talking of course about Skillshare
Skillshare is a phenomenal online
learning platform it's got over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more now you might know I've talked
before about 16,000 classes 18,000
classes they just keep adding thousands
of classes so now they've got 20,000
classes in all of those things you can
take classes in social media marketing
illustration data science mobile
photography creative writing
I shouldn't even give those examples
because they just have classes in
practically everything anything you want
to learn just about you can get on
Skillshare so whether you're trying to
deepen your professional skill set or
trying to start a side hustle or explore
a new passion Skillshare is there to
keep you learning and thriving now one
thing we do in modernity because all we
do is kind of passively consume content
is we just turn on a screen and we look
like we're just kind of stare you know
like that and that isn't good you won't
make yourself better you won't feel good
you'll feel lethargic and useless go on
and make something of yourself you know
right now one class that I really like
is a photo shop so you can go I don't
really know anything about Photoshop
doesn't seem that hard to learn but it's
just one of those things you have you
just it's good to have access to be able
to do it blog right onto Skillshare you
can learn it right there
drew and we did the another Kingdom
podcast he went and started looking up
social media marketing and had to do
podcast it's really really good I
obviously haven't looked up how to do
podcasts yet I figure I'll do that
around the 300th episode so right now
right now you can join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents practically free and
you can get access to all of these
things trust me you need a lot of skills
in the modern world if you want to look
for me when ben shapiro
in here finally and fires me I'm gonna
need some skills so I can keep my side
hustle going go to skill share calm /
Michael mi CH AE L get two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents Skillshare dot-com /
Michael to start your two months now
Skillshare comm / Michael okay it's
National Prayer day this is a very good
day we're going to be very thankful
because at one time I a priest that I
listened to in New York he said that
there were three prayers that you should
always be saying I love you thank you
and I'm sorry today we're going to be
focusing on the former - we can all
repent in our own time and you know flog
ourselves and things like that probably
we should all do it but we've got a lot
to be thankful for because Michelle
Obama let's just begin with the first
lady first ladies first she is no longer
the first lady here is Michelle Obama
talking at Temple University everything
it takes to succeed I know that you are
me and if I can be standing here as your
forever first lady
then you can do anything you put your
mind if I well you can if ifs and buts
were candy and nuts we'd all have a
Merry Christmas you're not the forever
first lady
apparently some Democrats on the
internet refer to Michelle Obama that
way but just imagine the disrespect of
that she gets up there and says I'm I am
your forever first lady forget about
that woman who's him who's actually the
first lady who cares about her I'm the
forever first lady this was not as bad
as Michelle Obama's classic gaffe when
she said and by gaffe I mean when she
accidentally was honest to the American
people and she said that she'd never
been proud of her country except when
they elected her president or her
elected her husband president that she
said otherwise I've never been proud of
my country this is pretty bad though
this uh she says you are me no we're not
we're not you we're not why are we you
why would we want to be you I don't we I
don't know that people like you very
much
no speaking of this speaking of the
National Prayer day and this me me me
you are me I'm your forever first lady
this is a classic Obama both her and her
husband the classic Obama Messiah
Complex here was Barack Obama speaking
just a little while ago you know I would
create a hundred or a thousand or a
million young Barack Obama's or Michelle
Obama's or you know the next group of
people who could take that baton this is
the Obama Messiah Complex it's why
people call Donald Trump a narcissist
Donald Trump is the most humble man in
the world compared to the Obamas
whenever they need an example of a good
thing or something good to be they refer
to themselves she says you are me you
say you are bright you're ambitious
you're talented you're the future you're
that no no that all of that pales in
comparison to you are me Barack Obama
when he says I want to change the future
I want to have a wonderful country and
the only the best way to do that is to
create little versions of me me the
greatest American ever because Barack
Obama said he doesn't really like
America he doesn't like the way that
America is that's why he wanted to
fundamentally transform America you
don't want to fund
they transform something that you love I
don't say to sweet little ELISA I love
you so much honey but I want to
fundamentally transform you that isn't
what you do and thankfully on the
National Day of Prayer they're no longer
in the White House
ha that is so nice Melania Trump has
been wonderful she's been a wonderful
first lady she's been graceful
she's been elegant she's been charming
and Michelle Obama was not Michelle
Obama said practically that she doesn't
like her country and she's disrespecting
the current first lady she's saying I'm
still the first lady I'm forever the
first lady and all these people they're
pretenders I'm forever the first lady
there was that incident at the
inauguration of President Trump's
inauguration when Melania Trump brought
Michelle a gift a nice little ritual and
she hands her a box and Michelle acted
as though this were some terrible thing
she said later on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show she said quote I mean this is like
a state visit so they tell you that
you're gonna do this they're gonna stand
there before you get this gift so it's
never happened so I'm sort of like okay
that's a direct quote from The Ellen
Show you know she said what am I
supposed to do with this gift everyone
cleared out no one would come and take
the box waa waa waa
just uh just not nice not elevated and a
lot of people said that Melania Trump
would would not be a for a good first
lady because she was a supermodel
perhaps Donald Trump's wealth and
success played some role and in his
charming her and wooing her and she has
been wonderful and yet you still hear
these people say Oh Michelle was so much
better
Michelle was not a good first lady I
know I try not to give too much flak to
the family of politicians except when
they make themselves a spectacle except
when they put themselves in the public
arena more than they have to be she
wasn't very good at being a first lady
and Melania has done a wonderful job
but of course that's all just the
prelude that's just the amuse-bouche
- the real thankfulness which is that
Barack Obama is no longer president
there's a major news story this week
that shows us just how wonderful it is
that Barack Obama is no longer president
but before we get to it before we get to
how Barack Obama more than any president
in recent history imperiled the world
order a an utterly failed president
before we get to that let's just that's
just recount some of his other failures
Barack Obama people forget this when you
know history wipes away all of these
sins and all of these bad decisions and
all of these bad policies essentially
everything the guy did was a failure and
made the country worse he entered office
during a bad recession and he made the
recession worse usually in economic
crises the deeper the recession the more
robust the recovery that's just the way
it works the Obama recovery which he
says it was the worst recession since
the Great Depression okay the Obama
recovery was the worst recovery in seven
decades it was the worst economic crisis
since the Great Depression you should
have had a good recovery but he didn't
because of his own policies during that
recovery GDP averaged a two point one
percent I think that's the worst
economic performance of any president
since World War two his economists said
you know that's just the way it is
that's just the new norm well that's the
best we can hope for yeah 3% for it
that's not gonna happen
Donald Trump comes into office he
immediately starts posting quarters of
three percent or greater economic growth
Barack Obama spent more on stimulus
money than all of the stimulus packages
ever combined you take every stimulus
bill in history add them together Obama
spent more with worse results with
counterproductive results so it's it's
adding insult to injury not only did he
not help the economy recover or allow
the economy to recover he also blew an
unprecedented amount of taxpayer money
on it during the Obama administration
millions of Americans fell below the
poverty line food stamps soared you
heard he was called the food stamp
president and then lefties racist
lefties said that that was a racist
comment and if this always boggles my
mind
what would they said that if you use the
phrase food stamps then that's racist
you're talking about black people say
black not all black people are on food
stamps what are you talking about you're
you're the one who said that I didn't
say that I it's absolutely not racist at
all no yeah when you call someone a food
stamp recipient you're calling them
black no that's you pal you're the one
who has that image in your mind not us
during the Obama administration the
national debt doubled
Millennials under the Obama
administration lived with their parents
at the highest rates since the Great
Depression there's a cultural aspect to
that and there's the economic aspect
Obama did a terrible job managing the
economy what else did he do oh right he
destroyed health care Barack Obama
destroyed one-sixth of the economy when
he upended our health care system and he
lied he lied blatantly to the American
people and he even admitted that he lied
he said oh you can keep your doctor
Oh premiums aren't gonna go up oh it's
okay PolitiFact named keep the if you
like your doctor you can keep your
doctor they named that the lie of the
year and Obama even admitted this when
when the premia started going up when
costs started to rise when people's
coverage changed he said well why you
didn't yeah and think you were gonna get
all that good stuff for nothing did you
say well yes we did we did think that
because you promised us that that's
exact all come on what you what you're
gonna believe me is Chicago politician
what's the matter with you that's
basically what he told us even he
snubbed his nose at the American people
he says what you were so stupid that you
believed me so the premiums rise and
after all of this we were told this is
universal health care this is the that
we've been wanting this for a hundred
years after all of that 30 million
Americans remained uninsured after all
of that appending a sixth of the economy
shooting up the prices of health care
premiums diminishing the quality of
coverage people losing their doctors and
30 million Americans uninsured an abject
failure how about on foreign policy well
on foreign policy Barack Obama managed
to lose a war that we had already won we
lot we had one of the Iraq war the troop
surge in 2007 one for us the Iraq war
Barack Obama chose to lose that war he
chose to pull out troops without a
Status of Forces Agreement he chose to
lose it what happened Isis came up in
its wake but don't that's okay
Barack Obama restarted the war in
Afghanistan for no reason
the actual reason that he did it was
because all of his campaign was running
against bush so he had to run against
the Iraq war but he didn't want to seem
like the weakling that he is so he had
to pretend that Afghanistan was a good
war I don't know what the Iraq war was
the bad war in Afghanistan's a good war
because he needed a good war to win his
election so he restarted that war and
it's no coincidence that
the vast majority of American military
deaths in Afghanistan occurred under
Barack Obama's watch not george w bush
over 75% under Barack Obama's watch they
told me if I voted for John McCain we'd
get more war in the Middle East and they
were absolutely right
what else did Barack Obama do on foreign
policy well all we hear these days is
about Russian collusion Donald Trump
colluded with Russia Donald Trump had a
bowl of borscht at the Russian Tea Room
in Manhattan in 1976 he colluded with
Russia
what did Barack Obama do Barack Obama
allowed Russia to invade Crimea and much
of Syria under his watch he gave them
Barack Obama said across from the leader
of Russia or the the fake leader of
Russia Medvedev the the Putin crony and
he thought that he was not being
recorded he thought their cameras and
the microphones were off and he said hey
listen I know that I said all that stuff
you know about how I'm gonna be tough on
you but direct quote I will have more
flexibility after my election to which
Medvedev responded duh duh I've who
transmits this information to Vladimir
Dada we actually have video of Barack
Obama colluding with Russia and
admitting that he's misleading the
American people on his stance on Russia
that's the only explanation if he
weren't misleading the American people
he would have said hey don't work we
don't have to wait until after the
election I'll just tell them that I'm
gonna give Russia flexibility but he
didn't he said in order to win my
election I have to pretend that I'm
tough on Russia but don't worry you can
invade and rape the lands of anybody
around you and do whatever you want what
else did he do on foreign policy well he
gave the Cuban slaveholding Castro
regime a bunch of money now in fairness
I have smoked a couple cigars in my life
so I but what he did was he decided that
he was going to give the Cuban regime
everything they wanted in exchange for
nothing in exchange for absolutely
nothing as a matter of national policy a
terrible idea you've got to give John F
Kennedy credit John F Kennedy liked
Cuban cigars as much as I do and he
ordered all of his boxes of Cuban cigars
and then he instituted a trade embargo
because he had to punish the regime for
upsetting the world order and for its
horrible human rights abuses stealing
property killing people enslaving
political dissidents is a
matter of national policy was a sound
policy Barack Obama said okay we'll just
give you whatever you want for nothing
then just a penultimate aspect of Barack
Obama's foreign policy he managed to
destroy Libya and Egypt both now he
didn't destroy it when he went and gave
apology tours and apologized for the
middlee for American policy in the
Middle East at the beginning of his
presidency but instead he turned on a
long-standing American ally Hosny
Mubarak let let him crumble and in Libya
he allowed that situation to decay so
it's now a failed state and led directly
to the chaos that allowed terrorists to
come in there and kill our first
ambassador overseas since 1979 that's
not a great record by all accounts a
terrible president but that's not even
his biggest blunder the thing that he
will be remembered for because Barack
Obama knew he said during his presidency
well I can't get anything passed through
Congress because I'm a horrible
negotiator and I don't have any friends
even and really in my own party but what
I what I can do is I have a pen and a
phone so I'm okay Congress isn't gonna
pass laws but I'm Anna sign executive
orders with a pen and a phone and this
leads to the Obama rule I guess you
could call it the Trump rule that which
can be enacted with a pen and a phone
can be repealed with a pen and a phone
hahaha so he was desperate at the end of
his administration to get the Iran
nuclear deal the big deal it was going
to prevent Iran from having nuclear
weapons and anybody who wasn't one of
the 22 year old failed novelist writers
who were advising him on foreign policy
for some reason who were in any of those
people people who had any proper sense
of the world said the Iranians are liars
they've been the greatest threat to the
world order since the Iranian Revolution
and you don't give them nuclear weapons
he said I can handle this I don't worry
I can handle this so here is what Barack
Obama promised us today after two years
of negotiations the United States
together where our international
partners has achieved something that
decades of animosity has not a
comprehensive long-term deal with Iran
that will prevent it from obtaining a
nuclear weapon
total lie complete lie everything about
that is not true
how do we know that because the Israeli
Prime Minister Bibi Netanyahu who during
the Obama era was the leader of the free
world he explains in a one of the
greatest presentations in modern
political history he didn't have any
program to develop nuclear weapons
anyway we consider nuclear weapons both
irrational as well as immoral well
tonight I'm here to tell you one thing
Iran lied big time after signing the
nuclear deal in 2015
Iran intensified its efforts to hide its
secret nuclear files a few weeks ago in
a great intelligence achievement Israel
obtained half a ton of the material
inside these vaults and here's what we
got 55,000 pages another 55,000 files on
183 CDs everything you're about to see
is an exact copy of the original Iranian
material you know if every TED talk were
like that I would watch them or every
it's like when they do the new iPhone
and they're walking they said this is
the new iPhone Bibi Netanyahu a master
showman and if this is really
humiliating for Barack Obama this was
supposed to be Barack Obama's one
lasting achievement and we now know it's
a total failure everything Obama told us
about the deal was a lie and every
promise of the deal is of course a lie
because it essentially hands Iran
nuclear weapons so with this me I mean
this was the last thing Obama had to
hold on to and it just turns out it was
an abject failure so all of the Obama
alumni who I think just her in 16 I so
happy 16th birthday to all of the Obama
senior policy advisers they all of these
alumni are out in force to defend the
Iran nuclear deal but it's very funny
because they're contradicting one
another so they I guess they didn't text
each other beforehand and say okay we're
gonna lie about it this way instead of
this
way Jim Garrity at National Review
pointed this out it's really funny Tommy
Vietor veter fighter I don't know former
National Security Council spokesman
under Barack Obama I he I believe was a
senior policy adviser for Obama during
eighth grade he said quote after years
of bashing US intelligence agencies for
getting Iraq WMD wrong Trump is now
cooking up Intel with the Israelis to
push us closer to a conflict with Iran a
scandal hiding in plain sight okay so
Tommy little Tommy's point of view at
Tommy's point of view is that he this is
all a lie Bibi Netanyahu and Donald
Trump are lying and look Barack Obama
his entire administration appeared to
hate Israel Barack Obama and his
campaign apparatus tried to get Bibi
Netanyahu kicked out of power there
so you're saying oh they're just lying
it's just a lie but ben rhoades another
former foreign policy adviser to the
president at the same time said quote by
reminding everyone of the well known pre
Iran deal history Netanyahu
inadvertently made the case for why the
Iran deal needs to stay in place without
it all the restriction restrictions on
Iran's program and the inspections
regime that verify compliance go away so
Ben Rose's answer to this is you know we
knew about all that such so these guys
both worked for Obama but the same guy
the same time same issue as a matter of
fact and one of them says oh this is a
total lie
totally cooked up by those those
Israelis and by Donald Trump and then
the other guy at the same time says yeah
no we knew about all of it so okay maybe
next time you should text each other and
figure out which lie you're gonna try to
spread to make up for your abject
failure this is a major difference
between the right and the left because
this hasn't been said enough Donald
Trump is much much better at being the
president than Barack Obama the country
under Donald Trump is much much better
off than under Barack Obama the world
order is much much better off under
Donald Trump than under Barack Obama the
left they said what are you Audrey
that's crazy what are you talking about
this is a major difference between the
right and the left the right likes the
thing itself the left likes the
appearance of the thing
without the essence of the thing the
right likes practical things the right
or the left rather prefers the
theoretical they say so here's an
example Donald Trump doesn't look like
the President does he he doesn't talk
like the president he doesn't walk like
the president he doesn't tweet like the
president so it's crazy and this is a
threat to the world order except he's
very good at being the president on
every marker on the economy on foreign
policy on on domestic policy certainly
on deregulation he's just very good at
it on making deals with people even on
getting the pop culture on his side
we'll talk about Kanye in a second but
he doesn't so Donald Trump doesn't look
like the president he's very good at
being the president Barack Obama
looks just like the president he talks
like the president he comports himself
like the president he uses all the right
words he smiles like the president smile
in a wink but he was terrible at being a
president he was too mean he was utterly
a failed president he has no
accomplishment in office everything was
a failure major difference between the
right and the left and now when people
clutch their pearls when they say but
talk Trump B he doesn't hold a
Chardonnay class right guys that's okay
that's fine he's good at being the
president and by the way people like
Kanye West are waking up to this which
brings us to what is sure to become a
daily segment Kanye watch I'm really
happy for you I'm let you finish Thank
You Kanye I appreciate that
the latest fallout from Kanye saying
conservative things what do we have
let's do a quick rundown before we get
to the mailbag a CNN op-ed writer wants
to censor Kanye West it will actually
want to shut him up the CNN writer says
quote the time has come to stop
amplifying his platform when he
continues to Miskin truth misconstrue
facts and distract the public from truth
shutting him down is not a matter of
censoring opinions it's a matter of
being responsible in how we elevate or
endorse the cult of celebrity in
situations that further espoused toxic
lies the cult of celebrity that the Left
invented at this point any outlet that
continues to allow Kanye West a platform
to knowingly speak such misinformation
is enabling the former exploiting his
status for ratings
on the misinformation by the way it let
me just point say this the one thing
that all of Kanye the Kanye's critics
are saying is that he lied about slavery
because he said if they're if you've
been a slave for 400 years that's a
choice that is true that is historically
and mathematically true now they're
saying well no he's talking about the
transatlantic slave trade the
transatlantic slave trade began in 1619
it didn't be the Dutch brought African
slaves to America in 1619 if that number
were true then the Trant then for 400
years that would mean that first of all
we'd be in the future it would have to
be 2019 right now and the transatlantic
slave trade would have to still be going
on which it's obviously not and ended
centuries ago the the point he was
making is that there is a mental
imprisonment and these guys make his
point for him on CNN they say no we're
not trying to mentally imprison you hey
hey guys in prison Kanye West stop shut
him up don't let him talk anymore so
that's one aspect another wonderful
aspect of Kanye watch which we all
predicted because cult politics is
downstream of culture and major pop
culture leaders who speak to specific
demographics can really affect politics
Donald Trump's approval rating among
black men in particular has doubled in a
week in one week that approval rating is
now at 22% previously it was at 11% also
at the same time his disapproval rating
among a black man has dropped
significantly from 87 percent to 71
percent according to this latest survey
the black men surveyed also who said
that they have mixed feelings about
Donald Trump rose from one point five
percent to seven point one percent so
you've got this twenty two percent
approval and then you've got this huge
bump five and a half point bump on mixed
feelings so what has mixed feelings mean
it doesn't mean they're starting not to
like Donald Trump it means they're
starting to like Donald Trump and before
you accuse that poll of being some
cooked up Republican thing that's from
Reuters Reuters is reporting that that
isn't some right-wing source so we're
seeing this political effect we're
seeing the Breitbart effect Andrew
Breitbart effect come into play the
politics is down stream of culture
that's great and
Kanye West has all the right enemies USA
Today ran a headline greatest rapper
alive how Kanye West evolved into just
another internet troll
Ramar yeah right okay okay buddy sure
sure yeah I'm sure I bet as many people
are reading USA Today or listening to
Kanye West
totally then the really heinous one is
USA Today ran a headline Chris Brown
tears Kanye West to shreds over his
slavery comments and this is an
improvement for Chris Brown because
Chris Brown usually just tears into his
girlfriends so it's good when he's
tearing into other male rappers I guess
Chris Brown said quote this is just
entertainment to y'all this man is a
clown wake the heck up Kanye he didn't
say heck please slavery was a choice
what hey Chris how about you learn to
read so that you can find out the Kanye
was exactly right please black people do
not follow West on his path to
destruction whatever help you think I
need get it for him ASAP and this really
bothers me it bothers me anytime
Chris Brown does anything because the
judicial system should have taken him
out back and put him down like Old
Yeller a long time ago Chris Brown is
just let's just read his police report
is publicly available this is just a
little snippet from the Chris Brown
police report the guy who's lecturing
Kanye West and Americans on how we
should comport ourselves historically
and politically this from the police
report quote a verbal argument ensued
and Chris Brown pulled the vehicle over
on an unknown Street reached over Robin
F that's Rihanna with his right hand and
opened the car door and attempted to
force her out Braun was unable to force
Robin out of the vehicle because she was
wearing a seatbelt when he could not
force her to exit he took his right hand
and shoved her head against the
passenger window of the vehicle causing
an approximate 1 inch raised circular
contusion Robin turned to face Braun and
he punched her in the left eye with his
right hand he then drove away in the
vehicle and continued to punch her in
the face with his right hand while
steering the vehicle with his left hand
the assault caused Robin Epps mouth to
fill with blood and blood to splatter
all over her clothing and the interior
of the vehicle
Braun looked at Robin and stated quote
I'm going to beat the S out of you when
we get home you wait and see that is
that is the only part that I can read on
air I think it
it's much much worse that that's Chris
Brown Chris Brown also got a neck tattoo
of a battered woman and he never served
any actual time for his many vicious
crimes this is the guy telling Kanye
West to get the help that he needs
absolutely outrageous there are very few
political or culture stories that
actually get me physically angry and
Chris Brown anytime he does anything is
one of them so that's where that's one
of Kanye's enemies then another one
finally Eric garland from the Atlantic
he writes that Kanye West this is a this
is a great one this is my favorite one
Kanye West is an agent of Moscow this is
the new thing this is the new I don't
like you on the Left if the left says
doesn't like you they'll just say you're
a Russian spy so Eric garland writes
quote both are witting or implausibly
unwitting at least assets of Russian
intelligence theater Roger stone likely
Jones's case or other corrupt elements
they're calling Kanye West
a witting asset for Russia a witting
Russian spy
Eric Garland by the way bills himself is
a strategic intelligence analyst that's
really something it's this is the best
it's sad because the Atlantic used to be
a good magazine and now it's 90% trash I
still subscribe but it's just awful and
this is it these are the this is the
strategic intelligence from the Atlantic
you can tell a lot of man but tell a lot
about a man by his enemies you can tell
a lot about look at all the enemies
coming after Kanye West I sort of have
to defend been here I spend most of my
time provoking been but there was the
funniest thing on Twitter yesterday is
when a shirtless vitamin salesman
started sending a lot of mean tweets
about Ben you can tell a lot about a man
by his enemies okay we've got to get to
the mailbag we're running way late so
before we get to the mailbag I'm sorry
we've got a great mailbag today but I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook in
YouTube if you are on those places go
over to Daley wire com if you already
there thank you you helped us keep the
lights on you know right now daily wire
is on Apple news it is a just a little
beacon of light in Apple news it's like
a lot of CNN and you cut through that
darkness and just get to the Daily wire
you can find this show on Apple iTunes
Google Facebook YouTube myspace saengil
geranyl a AOL Instant Messenger
Commodore 64 Palm Pilot I think we have
a version on Palm Pilot do you find a
lot of places if you subscribe to daily
wire it's 10 bucks a month 100 dollars
from annual membership you got me the
end replevin show them in Shapiro show
my conversations coming up folks you can
ask questions in the conversation I will
answer them everybody can listen for you
can ask questions many are called few
were chosen
none of that matters oh that's really
good let's just see is is Michelle Obama
the forever first lady is she
no Melania Trump is the first lady what
is is Baraka are we gonna have a million
Barack's and Michelle's now Kanye West
is talking like a conservative
Republican in quoting Thomas ol oh oh oh
my gosh I we got to go to a break go to
daily wire calm I've got a recover from
how delicious that was
let's get into the mailbag because we're
running out of time and these are great
questions from Tyler oh Michael the
Great and Powerful I've been hearing
people say that Islam and Christianity
are the same religion with a few minor
misunderstandings can you please shine
your all-knowing wisdom down upon them
thanks big fan yeah sure they're not
they're different religions obviously I
suggest you read the scriptures of both
the Quran and the Bible and the writers
people have written and Theological
writers about Islam and Christianity the
big difference between the two is that
Islam developed six centuries after
Christianity as a Christian heresy it
became something more than that probably
but it developed as a Christian heresy
we know this because the religion began
when Muhammad visited a historian or
Arian Monk we're not sure what what
Christian heresy he was in Syria is the
name was bashira he was up there on a
merchant trip with his uncle Abu Talib
and he spent a lot of time with him and
afterward concocted a version of
Christianity that is in keeping with
other heretical traditions and most
heresy just it can't come to grips with
mystery so Christ is both perfectly
divine and perfectly human various
heresies say he's entirely human or he's
entirely divine the the big difference
probably you would say that Islam is
more political it's more nationalist or
pan-pan Arab it's it's more for a
particular people but those are all
these are all kind of minor observations
or criticisms that one could debate the
big difference is that Islam denies the
cross of Christ so Islam says that they
crucified him not it speaks very highly
of Jesus but this says they crucified
him not and there are various theories
as to how Jesus was up on the cross and
then not crucified plenty of people have
written about this Saint Paul writes
about such proclamations six centuries
earlier he writes there were many
walking and I tell you now even weeping
who deny the cross of Christ who are
enemies of the cross of Christ
because the cross of Christ overcomes
death it's where the logic of the
universe the logos becomes incarnate and
dies for our sins to redeem all of
mankind
it's a God of perfect reason it's it's a
heaven of immaterial delight and Islam
poses something different it's a God who
is not confined by reason a God who's
not necessarily the logos a God who can
be wrathful in irrational ways and a
world in which death has not been
conquered a world which which promises
material delights in heaven those are
very different visions of the world
those are very different religions now
it's commonly taught by people who
haven't read any of these things then
have no familiarity with either of the
religions that oh you know we all
worship the same God not so different
religions worship different gods that's
what makes them different religions if
they worship the same God they would be
the same religion wouldn't they they
would manifest in the same ways but when
we see vast differences in religion we
know that they're worshiping something
different from the James dear Michael
fascism seems so unlikely today and it's
a dip does it I don't know I look around
college campuses and it seems very
likely he goes on and it's difficult to
imagine its philosophical appeal last
century could you attribute the rise of
atheism nihilism during the 20th century
as something that caused the appeal of
fascism seems to me that totalitarian
fascist States forced their own religion
of government down the throats of their
subjects do you think there was an
ideological appeal to fascism or was the
movement based on emotion and feeling
thank you guys thanks you guys and gals
at the Daily why are the only thing
keeping me sane these days that's a very
good question
because I actually disagree with your
read of fascism or your reaction to
fascism I'll say also that one can't
really separate plain objective facts
from the way that we react to them from
the way that we have ascribed value to
them or that we have emotion about them
those that distinction is I think
complicated and probably not a good one
to make oh the appeal of fascism makes
all the sense in the world it's a very
appealing political ideology
without God it makes all the sense in
the world without God because without
God there are there's no natural law
without natural law there are no
national natural rights the American
version of conservatism only exists
because of the profound radically
Christian character of America we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal and endowed by
their creator we know this from a
governor Winthrop in the model of
Christian charity that baptized all of
America in the early 17th century
we'll read that a little bit later but
we know this from the pilgrims the first
Americans the people who founded the
first American colonies where we trace
our foundation were Radical Christian
zealots fascism replaces God of course
it's reacting to a world of atheism and
nihilism and there it has to overcome
that nihilism with something everybody's
got to serve somebody so fascism
replaces God with neo pagan idols the
nation-state or the people or the fashi
you know binding us all together it's
it's a reactionary philosophy it's
reacting against as you point out
atheism materialism rationalism
positivism it's reacting against that I
react against that too I don't like
those things either but that's what
makes it so seductive is when you react
to all of those things that we don't
like about modernity without God you
just get the mirror image of all of
those things which is equally
ungratified some say the world will end
in fire some say in ice this is what the
the alternative right gets so wrong is
they they are reacting against all the
right things but they're reacting in the
wrong way because their reaction lacks
God it lacks the the crux pun very much
intended of Western civilization and so
it's a horrific caricature it's it's
exactly the flipside of leftism
good question from Kevin hi Michael my
20 year old son is a devout Christian
he's been dating a wonderful girl for
about four years
for the past year she's been struggling
with her Christian faith to the point
that she's not sure she can call herself
a Christian they have a very good
relationship they're both committed how
should I advise my son regarding his
relationship with her and how can he
help her with this struggle well I I
mean I was in her shoes when I was 20 I
was vaguely atheistic or agnostic at the
time and
I'm certainly not I think it's perfectly
normal to go through those sorts of
phases and I think it actually helps
ones faith because when you come back
you have the zeal of a convert even
though you're just a revert I think it's
fine look the truth above all things
she's confused right now and she's
questioning things and maybe she's
reacting appropriately against incorrect
interpretations of True Religion maybe
she's reacting against heresies maybe
she's reacting against misunderstandings
of Christianity that's good to react
against those things that the truth
above all things just have your son say
keep cool keep calm and explain the
world as as he sees it and you don't
have to worry about those things got you
know got you do your best God will do
the rest but I wouldn't worry too much
because there is a right answer and if
you are patient with patience is a
virtue if you're patient I think the
truth will come out as long as
everybody's in dealing in good faith
from Kenneth how much more time do we
have we got a little bit more time if we
have to accept people because of their
immutable characteristics such as being
gay however sexual orientation how is it
that it is illegal in California to have
a sex change material or it might be
banned in California to promote sex
change material but at the University of
Texas they are going to treat
masculinity as a mental health condition
there's this bill in California that
wants to ban all efforts to change one's
sexual orientation and it's true not
just at the University of Texas but all
over the country now we hear about toxic
masculinity this is a mental health
disorder as being studied by government
agencies and public agencies it's
because there are total hypocrites and
lunatics but it we don't need to take
that seriously that isn't they are not
being rational and we don't have to take
irrationality seriously but we should
watch out for that phrase I did this
Prager you video on the importance of
precise language the left now is using
this euphemism toxic masculinity to
refer to manliness
now manliness has two sides there's the
gentleman there's the hero there is the
good guy and there is the rapist and the
war monger and the villain it cuts both
ways and you have to do the you have to
be on the right
light of that you have to use manliness
in a good way with the left is using
that phrase to say masculinity is bad
per se manliness is bad per se but it's
not there's a good manliness and we have
to always exhibit it and the more it's
and it's a very manly thing to correct
people's errors in a patient but
confident way all right from Christopher
hey Michael I'm a huge fan of the show
and listened daily as someone who's one
of those heathen pagans you mentioned on
made a while purchase knocked to your
former German listeners why is it that
been and yourself are so critical of
anything pagan I understand a ton of
people who are pagan and just or just
those spiritual lefty commune types but
some of us are conservatives that just
happen to have differing religious
beliefs sincerely Chris thank you for
the note Chris thanks for watching daily
and since you watch daily you'll get
this edifying answer I hope it's because
you might have those differing religious
beliefs but they're wrong they aren't
they aren't true it's not it just isn't
good and that's why we're harsh on it
because it isn't true
we're harsh on a lot of things that
aren't true and aren't good now look
there are plenty of people who have good
intentions and who say I don't do any I
don't sacrifice children or whatever
okay I don't think you sacrifice
children necessarily plus America
sacrifices a million children a year but
paganism itself is just wrong and bad
and you shouldn't do it the word pagan
comes from the word pagano's which means
village rustic really it really means
hillbilly or hick it's like a kind of
uneducated rough stupid person this is
where you get the words like pi e or
Paisano and italian a paisan or peasant
in English they don't have good
connotations paganism is idolatrous but
it's the natural state of man Edwin
Bevan writes about this very well Lewis
and Chesterton allude to this paganism
is the natural state we're in the world
we don't have access to theology and
unless we are in civilization and so
strenght we know that the world is
spiritual and material the paganism
recognizes this too and it becomes
superstitious so we ascribe the
metaphysical things to various spirit
and it's it's idolatrous essentially
idolatry is the gravest of mortal sins
because it's an attempt on God's divine
majesty
everybody's got to serve somebody that's
why paganism exists we have to ascribe
things that we see in the world the
immaterial things that we and
metaphysical things that we experience
all the time we ascribe it to something
but it's it's false religion it's
superstition and it's ultimately
unsatisfying there is a theology that's
the study of God there is a true God and
there is false religion so the reason
we're harsh on it is that that is it is
false religion and it's and it's rustic
I mean there's a reason why it's the
natural inclination of man is because if
you're holding uneducated then you'll
fall for that
it doesn't make you stupid it just means
you haven't thought deeply about these
things or read deeply about these things
but over time when one does those you
arrive at theology and and there there
is revelation here as well there has
been revealed truth and that's where you
get to Christianity so I encourage you
to to study that a little bit and to
look into it and pray about that on
national prayer day because as I alluded
to in the question about fascism when
you react in politics in ways that are
not grounded in true religion it doesn't
necessarily have awful results but it
certainly can and it trends that way
these things are very insidious the
Bible is very clear God is very harsh
when people worship pagan idols doesn't
turn out well they get lots of leprous
sores and you know storms and locusts
and things like that so there's a reason
for that it isn't just because the Bible
is kooky is it oh how crazy that is no
it's really saying something about human
nature and religion so I would I would
think about that and and you know and
we'll all pray for you on National
Prayer day and you can pray for us from
Spencer we'll do a couple more than
we'll have to wrap it up Oh grand
Monsignor of the cough Feis Knowles do
you think elites whether aristocratic or
academic are necessary for the
preservation and transmission of culture
if so can we attribute the current
degradation of Western culture to the
egalitarian tendencies of democracy that
have also removed us removed from us the
injustice of hereditary privilege I'll
skip
that last part yes of course aristocracy
is a good thing Aristo s' means the best
and Chrissy or Grazia it means power so
yes there you need the best to transmit
culture because you need to transmit the
best culture the trouble is though right
now the people who would be our
aristocrats aren't the best they are
they are not the best of men Plato
writes about the best of men and they're
not they pretend that they are but we
don't have an aristocracy because our
culture is totally degraded so yes
aristocracy is a wonderful thing but an
integrated culture such as ours I don't
give media elites or academic elites
much credence that that seems to be gone
and you can find the remnant here or
there that you can look toward but right
now probably democracy which is the
opposite of aristocracy right
aristocracy is government by the best
democracy is government by the people
democracy is probably the worst form of
government except for all of the others
at our disposal right now okay last
question and then and then a little
sign-off for prayer day from Ivan dear
Michael recently I started hanging out
with an ex-girlfriend and well we only
date for five months we only dated for
five months it was a tumultuous
relationship that had many ups and downs
but ultimately ended because I could not
deal with her drinking problem she ended
up kissing another dude at a party while
drunk which led to me dumping her deep
down I since she's a good person who may
have in fact cared deeply for me but
who's just going through a bit of a
party phase which I myself went through
but have since left as it ultimately
brought me unhappiness am I making a
mistake in trying to form a friendship
with her in the hopes of one day
possibly rekindling our relationship or
should I spare myself the humiliation
and part ways for good PS if Kanye ends
up running for president in 2024 would
you appear in a commercial for him like
you did for Cruz in 2016
I've got some more commercials coming
down the pike look for that coming up
soon I won't
I won't comment yet on future president
West yeah you should just dump her and
not and not try to form another
relationship with her that's a terrible
idea don't humiliate yourself she's made
out with another dude in front of you
are you out of your mind what's the
matter with you
I feel like Don Corleone e talking to
Johnny Fontaine what's the matter with
you get a hold of yourself you're gonna
act like I'm
and no don't do it if she comes
groveling and begging and saying I'm
sorry I have totally changed my mind and
you know I was so wrong and please
please forgive me crying at your feet
then maybe consider it but don't go
crawling back and say please light do
you like me are you better now I
understand no no are you kidding me no
no I wouldn't I wouldn't even talk to
her she comes begging talk to her
otherwise No
okay before we get to that it's real
real turn-the-other-cheek for her
National Prayer day before we say
goodbye there's one last thing I'd like
to do because it's a National Day of
Prayer I would like to remind us of the
baptism of America one of the one of the
early blessings to America which came
from a governor John Winthrop in 1630
was written aboard the Arabella that
came over to to what would become the
United States in 1630 a model of
Christian charity this used to be
required reading everywhere now it's
probably banned in schools but if this
is an essential American foundational
text so we can read it before we say
goodbye it's very long you should read
the whole thing here are the big quotes
that are always pulled out governor
Winthrop for we must consider that we
shall be as a city upon a hill the eyes
of all people are upon us so that if we
shall deal falsely with our God in this
work we have undertaken and so cause him
to withdraw his present help from us we
shall be made a story and a byword
through the world but if our hearts
shall turn away so that we will not obey
but shall be seduced and worship other
gods our pleasure and profits and serve
them it is propounded unto us this day
we shall surely perish out of the good
land whither we pass over this vast sea
to possess it therefore let us choose
life that we and our seed may live by
obeying his voice and cleaving to him
for he is our life and our prosperity
happy National Prayer day I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you next week
[Music]
the Michael Dole show is a daily wire
forward publishing production executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer Mathis
Glover our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by alex zingara audio is
mixed by mike core amina herons makeup
is by Jeshua Avera copyright forward
publishing 2018